avec nous l'économiste et sénateurs
clément gignac bonsoir clément gignac
bonsoir alors est-ce qu'on atteint à 6,7
pour cent le sommet où est ce qu'on va
voir des hausse encore plus prononcée de
l'inflation dans les prochains mois mais
pour répondre à votre question en
variation annuelle gérard j'ai bien
vu je m'explique si on regarde les
tendances des derniers mois commencent à
s'accélérer donc ça se pourrait que le
taux annuel qui est la variation de
l'inflation sur 12 mois aux caennais de
dépassement et blessait pourçain garde l
esprit qu aux etats unis c'est 8.5 pour
ça et là ses derniers mots le canada a
tendance à accélérer donc pour m en
termes de variation annuelle ça sera
peut-être juste uniquement à tort au
début de l'été qu'on verrait peut-être
l'un se met autour de ces petits 2008
pour ça cette bibitte pour s'appuie en
plus on a l'impression que c'est
généralisé
l'énergie bond savez le logement aussi
les aliments sa touche directement le
portefeuille des ménages
oui fx humain donc c'est pour ça que les
scanners son indépendance a enlevé les
énergies sales indiquent les gens paient
pour c'est bien vrai oui mais juste pour
voir la tendance sous jacente
l'inflation fondamentale des tendances
l'autre et on est quand même un 4 points
8 % sont explosés l'énergie au canada
aux états-unis 6.5 donc la réalité c'est
qu'on voit une accélération ce même si
on enlève les énergies et les mains
énergie qui sont avec des palois guerre
en ukraine du bois sont donc clairement
il ya une accélération et c'est pas les
salaires qui sont la cause de
l'inflation comme ça avait les râles
puisque ça là quoique moins rapidement
que l'inflation et donc que fait la
banque du canada dans ce contexte
beaucoup d'économistes qui se prononce
en dix ans va augmenter encore d'un demi
point de pourcentage mais peut-être plus
à partir du mois de juin
moi je suis d'accord que faut accélérer
la cadence vaut mieux augmenter plus
rapidement plus vite c'est les leçons
qu'on ne tire est un des années 90
années 80 si on tarde trop pour
augmenter des taux d'intérêt pendant
plus longtemps est finalement il monte
plus haut que si on agit rapidement
d'une façon plus musclée donc moi je
suis partisan d'une hausse de 75 points
de base aux besoins garder l'esprit
qu'actuellement la politiquement et est
encore très expansionniste on devrait
avoir un taux d'équilibré autour de 2 me
soit pour cinquièmement avec une
économie qui tourne à pleine capacité or
le taux directeur est encore à 1% donc
on ne tardez l'an passé au début de
l'année à se mettre en branle et l'homme
à ce moment le faut accélérer la cadence
garder l'esprit qu'on voit un autre
chiffre d'inflation avant la prochaine
réunion de la banque du canada donc ce
prochain chiffres d'inflation sur le
décisif pour savoir si ces 50 75 ou même
100 points de base vaut mieux bouger
plus vite c'est ce que mr greenspan
président la réserve fédérale fed en
milieu des années 90 avait permis
d'éviter une récession on a vu un
prolongement de cette économie qu il y
avait même bouger général en
2003 puis à l'automne et va fait même 75
points de base sur 12 mois y avait
augmenté de taux directeurs de 300
points de base mais là avec la guerre on
a vu les grandes institutions révisé à
la baisse leurs prévisions de croissance
économique l'inflation qui est élevé les
taux d'intérêt qui pourrait s'accélérer
est ce qu'il ya des risques de plus en
plus élevés de récession
pourrait provocation l'airé sont plus
élevés il va sans dire on parle du pôle
tes de 15 ou 20 % comme c'était
peut-être le couple 3 4 mots on papotait
d'une probité de 35% gardez à l'esprit
que la croissance économique sera quand
même très robuste encore cette année ou
au début de l'an prochain puisque si
regardez des prévisions de la banque du
canada la croissance économique sera
moindre pour cent supérieure à celle des
états unis et on voit aussi des
gouvernements ont des politiques
expansionnistes si vous regardez budget
du québec on injecte de l'économie de
l'argent dans l'économie donc le 500
dollars c'est quand même 3 milliards de
dollars que déjà sinistré donc mais
c'est zéro point 6% du pib si vous
regardez les élèves le budget du québec
donc ça contribue à alimenter
l'inflation je comprends que on veut
venir en aide mais cependant sa
d'envoyer un chèque à tout le monde non
plus comment il a décidé de faire don au
fédéral
si vous regardez le dernier budget il y
est beaucoup moins inflationnistes
puisqu'on parle d'un 2 0 point 2 % du
pib comme nouvelles mesures comme un
sergent si du côté de québec oui ok je
comprends piste c'est intéressant
d'avoir les chiffres mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui trouvent de toute façon que
tous les programmes ont été
inflationnistes depuis deux ans
premièrement et que les dépenses qu'on
maintient quand même que les déficits
qu'on maintient dans le budget fédéral
ça aussi ça alimente l'inflation qu'est
ce que vous en pensez mais prudemment je
pense que si on regarde par le passé si
on regarde du rang de pandémie je pense
le gouvernement devait faire ses bonnes
choses le puisque sinon on aurait eu une
grave récession comme adele et l'ancien
gouverneur de bones canettes on ne peut
pas blanc mais un pompier de voir tous
ces trous d'où tenez senti que c'était
la bonne chose locon peut pas qu'on
reprochait au gouvernement c'est de
pouvoir avoir extension est peut-être
pendant un peu trop longtemps les
programmes et que là et ont continué à
l'est avec des défenses et qu'on n'ait
pas décidé qui des deux retours liquide
et budgétaires tout ça alimente
l'inflation mais je vous dirais que le
gros responsables actuellement c'est la
banque du canada aussi la réserve
fédérale qui ont trop tardé à commencer
et taux d'intérêt s'est pas perdue on a
encore le temps de récupérer mais
pourquoi se mettre un brin de façon plus
musclée plus vite aux contres aider afin
d'impressionner dernier point est une
question qui nous revient taux toujours
clément gignac taux fixe ou taux
variable dans les circonstances mais
disons que les taux hypothécaires sont
regardés detroit 5-1 ont déjà augmenté
considérablement
donc le 6 3 ou 6 mois la réponse est
laissé des taux fixes par vous verrez
pas ce genre de taula de façon
très bientôt à ce stade ci si quelqu'un
est en mesure d'opter pour un tour de
passe à travers cette hausse de
l'inflation je ferai plus - taux
variable au moment où on se parle
puisque les taux fixes ont déjà quand
même passablement augmenté et des
banques centrales sont très sérieuses de
retourner à 2 3% l'inflation donc à ce
stade ci pour peut-être mieux choisir
taux variable ou fixe
sauf si vous êtes un jeune ménage et
voyager très serré bien là ce moment là
on prend pas de chance un bon prof taux
fixe merci pour ces explications claires
clément gignac bonne soirée au plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit